cryptocurrencies and wall street have
mostly been operating in two separate
worlds
until now we are listing a stock on the
nasdaq
coinbase the us's most popular
cryptocurrency exchange
is going public and that's a big deal
for both wall street and the crypto
community not only does it make crypto
and bitcoin a little more acceptable it
actually now gives investors
another way to invest in bitcoin the
company allows users to trade and store
cryptocurrencies and charges fees on all
transactions it
profits when cryptos like bitcoin trade
higher and in the first quarter of 2021
when bitcoin's price doubled coinbase's
revenue was 1.8 billion dollars
coinbase's revenue being tied to
bitcoin's value has led investors to
wonder if the platform's share price
will be just as volatile as bitcoin
which is known for its big price swings
coinbase has said it wants to do much
more than selling bitcoin
we're gonna basically try to make uh
make it easy for our customers to access
all the different things they might want
to do with crypto the crypto industry
has so far
mostly grown outside of the traditional
and regulated investment system
and has an image of being a risky asset
also due to hacks and cybercrime
this listing is meant to help legitimize
it so will coinbase's public debut be a
turning point for crypto
nasdaq set the reference price for
coinbase at 250
which would give the company a valuation
of about 65 billion dollars that's about
eight times its valuation in a 2018
fundraising round
to understand why the listing is making
waves on wall street you have to
understand what attracted some 56
million users to the platform
when bitcoin first emerged around 2010
it wasn't exactly easy to trade
wsj crypto reporter paul vinier has been
following bitcoin and coinbase
for quite some time i've been writing
about bitcoin since 2013.
in the early days you had to basically
download the bitcoin
software the actual program itself run
it on your computer
maintain a wallet maintain a node on the
network
and for a lot of people it was just
technologically
too big a deal for them to deal to
bother with coinbase was created in 2012
and was one of several platforms that
offered an easier way for people to buy
sell and store cryptocurrencies the
whole point of it was
to be very simple and if you look at the
website it is is basically
a very simple way to buy and sell
bitcoin
the company makes money by charging a
small fee when people buy or sell crypto
much like a currency exchange would if
you were changing say
euros to dollars and it's these
transaction fees that make up the vast
bulk
96 of coinbase's revenue and what has
tied the company's performance directly
to those crypto markets
the company made some 322 million
dollars in profit last year as crypto
gained more legitimacy among traditional
investors
over the last year it has it's become
hip right
bitcoins usage has been sort of codified
that really opened the door for a lot of
professional money managers
institutional money
hedge funds to come in and start playing
in this little
exciting sandbox and then in 2021 crypto
has matured to
a point where we wanted to be able to
share with all investors and all
the public actually how far the industry
has come and we thought one way we could
do that was by going public
rather than going public through an ipo
the company has decided instead to do it
via a direct listing like companies like
spotify and palantir
that means that they'll save the money
that they would have paid to investment
banks but their shares will be sold by
whoever currently owns them
so the company won't directly make any
money in the process
what makes coinbase's listing really
unique is that it's the first time a
listed company's stock performance will
be so closely linked to crypto markets
this is the first sort of direct
connection between the capital markets
and the bitcoin markets
while there is some small crypto based
companies that trade publicly in the us
and overseas
none handles as much crypto as coinbase
which has some 223 billion dollars of
assets on its platform
that's why share price is expected to
follow the path of its main currencies
bitcoin and ethereum
and that could provide a unique
opportunity for traditional investors
you can almost look at the stock as an
index
on cryptocurrencies if you are a
mainstream stock investor
and you you really don't want to deal
with bitcoin itself
you can buy coinbase stock uh it will be
part of the daily conversation now
oh what did coinbase stock do today was
it up was it down although crypto price
swings can be enticing to investors
seeking high volatility
for coinbase having its share price tied
to that fluctuating market
creates a lot of risk and may put off
some investors
if you think the dow had a bad day
bitcoins was worse it wasn't just
bitcoin getting bashed at one point the
global cryptocurrency market lost
over 100 billion dollars in just 24
hours equities
going higher bitcoin going lower in 2019
when the price of bitcoin fell coinbase
lost some 30 million dollars
in coinbase's regulatory filing for the
direct listing they had a very long
section
on risk they understand that bitcoin is
going to go up and down
and it's not just volatility that makes
bitcoin risky the currency has a long
checkered history of being linked to
cyber crime hacking and theft
coinbase has never been hacked i have to
make you know be clear about that
that's a really big deal but if coinbase
was ever hacked if their security was
breached
if bitcoins were ever outright stolen
from their
from the wallet that people have on
coinbase from their accounts
that would be a disaster for coinbase we
always
want to keep cyber security top of mind
we've got a cyber crime insurance policy
against that
but it doesn't mean that cyber security
is not a big big threat we have to keep
in mind all the time to try and distance
itself from the risks of bitcoin
coinbase says it has
built out a one billion dollar war chest
and has started to offer a wider range
of products that it can sell to its
consumers
coinbase is we're a retail you know app
where people have their primary
financial account where but we have an
exchange underneath that we have a
custodian under that we have an
institutional business
we also have a commerce merchant
payments business they're prepared to
ride the ups and downs
but they also want to build a bigger
boat to deal with those ups and downs in
the future
those investing in coinbase are betting
that bitcoin will continue to grow and
gain more legitimacy
but if the currency were to crash as of
now that could be a big problem for the
reputation of both crypto and coinbase
i think it's really important to
remember that historically
bitcoin has gone through a no a few
periods like this where the price has
gone very very high
and come crashing down just because
coinbase is now public
just because bitcoin's perception has
been changed in the markets
that doesn't mean that bitcoins never
going to go down again